[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
my hero academia video thank you so much
for your support on our every quirk
explained class 1a and on our every
villain explained videos during the
every villain video I asked which my
hero academia video you want to see next
and while I was hoping for something
simple like Minoru Minetta explained so
many of you wanted to see a video about
all the pro heroes well you asked for it
and so in this video we will talk about
all the known pro heroes in my lyric
edenia the strongest heroes the coolest
heroes the top ranked heroes and of
course midnight the 18-plus
only hero she's in here too and while we
know more about some of the heroes than
we know about others I hope that having
them all here in one place will be
helpful to you and now if you are ready
to go
be sure to 100% Detroit smash that like
button and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe for more my
hero academia videos in the world of my
hero academia professional heroes are
people who use their unique abilities
known as quirks to help other people and
to preserve order the most successful
and effective heroes get paid by the
government to perform their heroic deeds
and this is what makes them pros
starting things off with the very first
heroes that we see in action in episode
1 of the anime and chapter 1 of the
manga we have calmly woods and mount
lady
Conway's real name is shin Jeannie Hsieh
but we have no idea what he really looks
like because we've never seen him
outside of his wood inspired hero
costume his quirk is referred to as
lumber or the lumber quirk its type is
emitter and it works a long range this
work enables calmly to produce tree
roots from his body and to use them as
weapons against his opponent he can use
his quirk to create a special attack
known as a lacquer change prison which
traps opponents inside a makeshift
wooden cage it can be a very effective
technique for heroes as it allows Conway
to confine multiple opponents at once
and he uses it on several members of the
League of villains during the hideout
raid arc in the manga due to the
wood-based nature of his quirk his power
is not effective against fire based
quirks then we have mount lady her real
name is Yu Takayama and we first meet
her as she jumps in to take down a
villain with a flying tick just as
Conway is preparing to use Locker chains
prison to stop him she is a young hero
and she enjoys the spotlight not shying
away from using her reputation as a hero
to self sponsored product but she also
demonstrates genuine bravery and
selflessness in important moment her
quirk is Giganta fication it's typist
transformation and it works at close
range mount lady's regular height is 162
centimeters or 5 feet 4 inches but her
quirk allows her to suddenly grow to a
height of 2,060 to centimeters or nearly
sixty eight feet some may not realize
that mountain lady cannot control how
big she get she can either be at her
normal height or at her max height but
nothing in between because of this she
is unable to make effective use of her
quirk unless she is out in the open so
cramped or confined spaces limit the
effectiveness of her quirks
next is recovery girl her real name is
Chiyo choose Angie and believe it or not
she is known as youthful heroine
recovery girl she is a nurse at the UA
and she uses her power to quickly heal
the students whenever they get injured
during training the name of her quirk is
recovery its typist transformation and
works at close range
recovery girl is able to boost and speed
up the natural healing process on
individual by essentially kissing their
booboo the quick recovery heals
instantly or very quickly injuries that
might otherwise take months to heal
however the cleric does drain the energy
and stamina of the person being healed
so recovery girl cannot heal too many
injuries too quickly or else the patient
will be in danger of exhaustion a hero
clearly better suited to play a
supporting rather than defensive role
she scores only a 1 out of 5 for both
power and speed but her technique and
intelligence stats are outstanding at 5
out of 5 according to the official my
hero academia character book then we
have gran torino a retired pro hero he
is roughly
in the same age bracket as recovery girl
gran torino used to be all my soul room
teacher at ua during his student days
and all might has a great respect for
and is actually very intimidated by his
former teacher the name of his quirk is
jet it's psifas mutant and it works at
close range gran torino squirt enables
him to jump around with incredible speed
as a result of air propulsion boosters
that are located on the soles of his
feet the heights to which he can jump is
limited because he can only propel
himself using the air that he can reel
in and his old age also limits the
frequency and extent to which he can use
his first gran torino sook work gives
him immense speed and strength the
momentum of his quick movements
increased the power of his physical
attack and he is shown to still be
capable of taking out multiple villains
on his own even at his age his speed
stats are off the charts at 6 out of 5
and he also scores a 5 out of 5 for
technique next is Nana Shimura a friend
of Gran Torino and all my former mentor
Nana Shimura was the seventh user of the
transferable work known as one for all
she was known for her commitment to
justice and for always doing her best to
help others with a smile on her face but
sadly sometimes after transferring hurt
work onto all might she was murdered by
the mastermind behind the legal villain
quirk one for all gave her superhuman
strength speed agility and reflexes but
I will talk more about why for all when
we get to all might himself along with
one for all nana Shimura is believed to
have possessed a second quark but we do
not know what type of quark it was then
we have launched rush for Ranchi russia
one of the unsung heroes of mine hero
academia the cooking hero run to rush
room or lunch rush is a pro hero and the
official cook at UA he wears a hero
costume that is clearly inspired by his
status as a chef we can only assume that
his quark is related to preparing
delicious food quickly and efficiently
for the students of UA up next is 13 the
space hero 13 wears a hero costume that
resembles a spacesuit and he was the one
who created the training facility
known as the unforeseen simulation joint
where the students of UA can practice
emergency rescue maneuvers he is
committed to his duties as a pro hero
and he has a firm belief that quirks
should be used to help others the name
of his quirk is black hole its type is
emitter and it works at medium range his
quirk enables thirteen to generate small
black holes that can suck in and then
disintegrate matter and light on an
atomic level although his squirt can
potentially become incredibly deadly if
used against people thirteen uses it's
primarily for removing hazardous debris
during rescue missions he scores an
impressive five out of five in
cooperativeness then we have in Kenya
the older brother of class 1a president
Kenya ADA and the man Kenya always looks
up to his real name is Penn sayyeda the
name of his quirk is unknown but it is
very similar to tenuous quirk called
engine so we could assume that it might
be called the same or perhaps his quirk
is called turbo since Ingenium is also
known as the turbo hero the quirks type
is mutant and it works at close range in
the same way that Tania has engines on
his legs in Kenya has these types of
engines on his elbows he uses the
engines to move around at great speed
and also to deliver powerful offensive
attacks because he doesn't have brakes
on his engines Ingenium has to be
careful so as not to run into a wall or
other hard objects while using his quirk
next is a balmy known as the snake hero
who a bunny has three different species
of snake growing out of her hair she is
a popular hero who is dedicated to her
work and when normal and asuka come to
her for their field training the three
of them appear in a commercial together
the name of her quirk is snake hair the
type is mutant and it works a medium
range you Obama can use the exceptional
senses and natural instincts of the
snake living in her hair to locate
people including victims stranded after
an incident or potential enemies she
scores a 1 out of 5 in power and two out
of five in speed but a stellar 5 out of
5 in technique Google ami shares the
same name and appearance as a character
in coca-cola Co she's earlier manga
series Omega donkeys ooh next is a hero
called power loader
his real name is Segura miyajima he is
au a teacher and he is known as the
excavation hero power loader his hero
costume consists of a steel helmet and a
number of other metallic objects that
cover his body he is in charge of
creating the hero costumes at UA and he
is able to maintain and upgrade existing
costumes with great expertise what we
know of his abilities is that he
possesses metallic claws that he can use
to dig on the ground and he is extremely
powerful
he scores an impressive 5 out of 5 in
power next we have Eraserhead his real
name is shota
Aizawa and he is the strict but fair
homeroom teacher for class 1a anyway the
name of his quark is eraser its type is
emitter and it works at long range
it's quark gives Eraserhead the power to
cancel out the quirks of others by
looking at them now obviously this is an
extremely useful ability to have in
battle but its limitations are that it
can only be used on one opponents at a
time and the eraser head cannot blink
while using it which results in his eyes
becoming dry and worn out also because
mutant type quirks are a permanent part
of their users body the eraser quark
does not work on them it only works on
transformation and emitter type quark
eraser head scores on off-the-charts 6
out of 5 and technique and he is also
known for his intelligence and strong
hand-to-hand combat skills up next we
have Tiger Tiger is a member of the
pussycat a pro hero team specializing in
mountain rescue he is strict and tough
that he believes that everyone including
the young you a student must undergo
rigorous training in order to become
real heroes the name of his quark is
Playa body or literally pliable body its
typist transformation and it works at
close range as a result of his quirk
Tiger can stretch his body in impossible
waves which allows him to get through
extremely narrow and cramped spots and
this comes in handy with the rescue
missions that he is involved with his
body might be pliable but this does not
mean that he had solved Tiger actually
scores a 5 out of 5 in power according
to the character book and we
Mandalay her real name is Shino Sasaki
and she is another member of the cat
themed hero team known as the pussycat
the name of her quark is telepath it's
type is emitter and it works at long
range her quirk enables Mandalay to
communicate with several people at one
time through telepathy but since the
other people she is communicating with
are not telepath they are able to
receive information from her but they
cannot respond until the communication
goes only one way she scores a 5 out of
5 and cooperativeness and this makes
sense since her quirk is well suited for
a team player after that we have pixie
bomb she is the third member of the
Pussycats and her real name is Rico -
chika WA she is an energetic and
attractive woman but due to the fact
that she is 31 years old and still not
married she is known to be actively
looking for a male suitor and she is not
above flirting with you a students like
Deku and Todoroki the name of her quark
is earth flow its type is emitter and it
works at long range her quirk enables
pixie Bob to control and reshape the
earth around her and use it as both a
tool and a weapon in combat the final
member of the Pussycats is rag doll her
real name is Tomoko Ishida toko and she
is known for being extremely energetic
and she was also once ranked as the
number 32 pro hero the name of her quark
is search its type is emitter and it is
target based with the help of her quark
ragdoll was able to conduct surveillance
on up to 100 people at a time including
their location and potential weaknesses
however she became the first person that
was shown to have her quark stolen from
her by a villain and this left her quark
with another known hero team in the
series is water horse a husband-and-wife
pro-hero team with water type quirks
they were killed in action while trying
to protect innocent civilians from a
villain known as muscular although they
lost their lives they managed to save
the civilians by injuring muscular to
the point that he was unable to continue
his attack and of course if you want to
learn more about muscular and the
villains check out our every villain
video link in the description next up is
Crimson Riot Crimson
riot is the pro hero that Kirishima from
class 1a is directly inspired by and he
pays tribute to his hero by choosing a
similar hero name for himself and of
course the names of canoe SEMA
ultimately chooses is red riot crimson
riot is known as a manly hero with a
strong reputation as we see what
midnight calls him that man among heroes
crimson riot we don't know much about
him other than the fact that he greatly
inspired Kashima and this could lead us
to speculate that perhaps his quirk was
similar to Konishi Maz hardening quirk
in some way but we cannot be sure then
we have Buster hero we know very little
about the buster hero other than the
fact that he has a jetpack and that deck
who knows about him and is a fan of his
work we also know that may hot cement
from class 1h was inspired by Buster
hero when she created some of her
gadgets but we don't know if the jetpack
that he wears is somehow connected to
his quirk as is the case with the
propulsion boots used by Gran Torino
or if he simply created a jetpack using
modern technology next we have gang Orca
real named kugel Sokka Mota his clerk
makes him a cross between a man and an
orca whale he is ranked as the number 10
pro hero the name of his clerk is killer
whale it's type is mutant and it works
at close range as a result of his work
game Orca can use the powers of a killer
whale even on shore he is large strong
an excellent swimmer and he can produce
a sound wave that paralyzes his
opponents his weakness is that being
part Marine Mammal makes him prone to
dehydration when he is not in water so
he always carries water with him in case
he needs to pour it on himself to
prevent dehydration just like Oh Bellamy
he is based on a character called Sokka
Mata from Kohei motorcoaches earlier
manga series called Omega donkey zoo
where zoo animals can take humanoid form
after that we have gun head the battle
hero gun head is a pro hero who
specializes in armed combat who Erica
chooses to join his agency and to train
under him during the field training art
its work is called Gatland
its type is mutant and it works a medium
range
one head has guns protruding out of his
arms and these guns are able to shoot
sharp materials made out of the protein
keratin his quirk is effective and close
and medium range combat and he scores a
5 out of 5 in power and next up is
midnight everyone's favorite dominatrix
memory Kiama is better known by her
alias the 18 plus only hero midnight she
is a pro hero who works at the UA and we
can only assume that she is very
effective in disciplining the students
since she is always carrying around a
whip with her the name of her quirk is
so novelist its type is emitter and it
works at medium range the word so number
list is actually the technical term for
a sleepwalker and this makes sense
because Midnight's quirk gives her the
ability to project a scent from her body
that puts her opponents to sleep
unsurprisingly Midnight's charms are
more effective on men than on women and
she scores a 5 out of 5 in technique
although what kind of technique we are
talking about here is anyone's guess
then we have hound dog real mam Rio in
we the pro hero hound dog is the
guidance counselor at UA his appearance
resembled a dog and he has been known to
growl like a dog when mad the name of
his quirk is dog its type is most likely
mutant and it works at close range we
have no specific information about how
this quirk actually works but we can
assume that similar to to you ah so a
sprog form pound dog is able to use the
special abilities that dogs have such as
speed agility and a strong sense of
smell and hearing next is native a pro
hero whose name and appearance is
clearly inspired by Native American
culture Native is shown to be brave
selfless and willing to sacrifice
himself to save you a student during a
battle against hero killer stain
unfortunately we have no information
about a squirt or the specific extent of
its power but we do know that on his own
he was no match for hero killer stain
next up is Despereaux a large man with a
muscular build he is sometimes referred
to as the punching hero the name of his
quirk is unknown but we know it gives
him superhuman strength and he scores a
5 out of 5 and
or his weakness is that his quirk is
completely based around physical power
so with villains such as the sludge
villain from the first episode of the
anime and the first chapter of the manga
death Goro is essentially powerless his
name is a reference to a Japanese word
that means fighting barehanded and after
that we have cement O's real name can
ishyama cement oasiz another teacher at
UA like his name suggests his body
appears to be made out of cement and
cement is also the name of his quirk its
type is emitter and it works on contact
as a result of his quirk cement toast is
able to control anything that is made
out of cement in his immediate vicinity
and this can be a powerful weapon in a
city but his quirk would be useless to
him in areas where there is no cement
such as in a forest although his cement
based quirk might make us think
otherwise
Cement oh scores only on three out of
five in power but it scores an
impressive 5 out of 5 in both
intelligence and technique next up is
backtrack backtrack is a firefighter and
a pro hero who focuses on rescue
operations
he carries a water tank on his back and
he can shoot water out of a cannon on
his shoulder the name of his quirk is
hydro Kinesis its type is emitter and it
works at medium range his quirk enables
backtrack to shoot out water and to
manipulate it into different shapes
which comes in handy in an emergency
situation the name of his Clerk is
likely a reference to telekinesis except
instead of being able to bend spoons
with his mind backdraft is able to
control and manipulate water next we
have sniped another you a teacher and
pro hero knifes appearance and
mannerisms resemble a cowboy he is an
expert marksman and possesses
exceptional aim the nameless quirk is
homing and its type is emitter his quirk
appears to enable snipe to actually
control the direction of bullets even
after he fires them and we can assume
the quirk works for both short and long
range as a result of his quirks life
scores are off the charts 6 out of 5 in
technique then we have present Mike real
name he's Ashiya mada present mike is a
you a english teacher and a pro hero he
is loud and except
Rick and he was the one who gave the
Eraserhead his hero name back when they
attended school together the name of his
quirk his voice excited a matter and it
works at long range befitting of his
loud personality present Mike's work
enables him to create incredibly loud
and high-pitched sound with his voice
this square can be very effective
offensively because it can literally
make an opponent's ears bleed
but the quirk is less effective in
places where sound doesn't travel well
such as in sealed off areas present Mike
wears a special speaker system around
his neck which lessen direct this work
whichever way he wants it to go he has
impressive stats overall and he scores a
5 out of 5 in both intelligence and
cooperativeness then we have NASA
a pro hero and the you a principal
animals developing quirks is said to be
incredibly rare in the world of my hero
academia but Nezha appears to be an
animal who became intelligent as a
result of his quirk and now lives
alongside humans as unequal the name of
his quirk is high spec and its type is
mutant as a result of its quirk mezu an
animal developed intelligence that is
even greater than the intelligence of
humans he is capable of speaking and
thinking critically and strategically
without a problem and he scores a 5 out
of 5 and technique and an off-the-charts
6 out of 5 in intelligence next is
ectoplasm a dedicated you a teacher and
pro hero he is well respected by his
peers and the general public the name of
his quirk is clone it's type is emitter
and it works at long range this quirk
enables him to eject an ectoplasmic
material out of his mouth that can turn
into multiple clones of himself he is
able to create up to 30 or more clones
at a time and he can also create one
huge clone that can trap an opponent
inside his body by devouring them with a
giant mouth because of the many
strategic possibilities that his quirk
provides EXO plasm scores of 5 out of 5
in technique then we have manual real
name Misaki mizushima manual is also
known by the amazingly ordinary name the
normal hero as that name suggests he has
an ordinary person
and appears to be a kind person overall
during the field training our Tanya EDA
chooses to work at Manuel's office
Manuel has a water-based quirk that
allows him to collect water around his
hand and he is so normal or average that
he scores a three out of five in
literally all categories and next up is
blood king real name Steketee Luke on
blood King is the homeroom teacher for
class one B at UA he is known for
encouraging his students to do their
best and to not get out shined by class
1a but he never takes us beyond the
realm of friendly rivalry the name of
it's quirk is a blood manipulation it's
type is emitter and it works at close
range as a result of his quirk blood
King is able to manipulate his own blood
and use it in battle he can shoot his
own blood out of his glove and harden it
in order to restrain opponents and he
can then bring the blood back into his
body once he no longer needs to use it
he also possesses exceptional physical
strength and speed and now for the top
ranked hero the number 5 pro hero
Shinya Cammy Harris or ed shot has the
appearance of a ninja the name of his
quirk is foldable its typist
transformation and it works at close
range
his quirk enables ed Shaw to fold and
stretch his body which give him great
stealth and agility this quirk is
similar to Tigers Playa body quirk in
nature except ed shot is able to
transform his body faster than the speed
of sound which makes it much faster than
Tiger head shot is even able to twist
and turn his own elastic body into a
sharp weapon the number four ranked pro
heroes real name is tuna hoo-hah kimoto
but he is better known by the alias best
genus he was the winner of the best
genus award for eight years in a row
which is where he got his hero name
believe it or not the best genus award
is 100% real and it is given to
celebrities who look the best in gene it
is actually one of the most prestigious
fashion Awards in Japan it is important
to mention that on top of being a
fashion icon he is also very strong and
brave Pro hero the name of his quirk is
fiber Master it's type is emitter and it
works at medium
this quirk enables best genus to
manipulate textile materials he can use
strings of fabric from clothing as
weapons both offensive and defensive and
he can also use fabric to restrain an
immobilize opponent he scores a 5 out of
5 in technique and is known as a
fiercely top fighter the father of
shuttle Todoroki from class 1-a ng
Todoroki or the flame hero endeavour is
the number two ranked pro hero even
though he is an extremely successful
hero and has a higher rate of resolve
cases that any other hero he is also
vain and jealous of all Mike for ranking
higher than him endeavour is notorious
for mistreating his wife and children
all in the pursuit of somehow surpassing
all might the name of his quirk is hell
flame its type is emitter and it works
at medium range as a result of his work
and ever is able to generate and
manipulate flame which makes for a
powerful weapon against all potential
opponents the quirk can be deactivated
it endeavor wishes it to be but he is
almost always seen with flames around
his body which speaks to his vanity and
the desire to stand out at all times he
is a stacked hero overall and he scores
a 5 out of 5 in power speed and
technique with a 4 out of 5 and
intelligence but only have 2 out of 5 in
cooperativeness and finally we come to
the number one ranked hero at least at
the beginning of the series all my
almost real name is potion or yogi and
along with being the number one ranked
pro hero he is also a teacher at UA he
is also known as the symbol of peace and
also want to destroy the current society
such as members of the League of
villains are especially interested in
killing almighty because they believe
that the current society and its values
would die along with him he actually has
to form his hero form is extremely
muscular and reminiscent of western
super heroes like Superman on the other
hand in his actual form he is an
extremely skinny and frail looking
individual the name of his quirk is one
for all its type is emitter and it works
at close range
one for all is a very interesting quirk
because it combines two separate works I
worked at stockpiles power and a quirk
that allows quirks to be transferred
from one
person to another all might has
superhuman strength reflexes stamina
agility and speed
once the quirk is transferred from one
person to another the one who transfers
that can still make use of some leftover
embers of the quark which is why all
mine is still able to use this power
even after transferring one for all onto
deku however these embers will
eventually run out all my twas the
eighth user of the one for all quark and
Deku is the ninth and current user the
true workings of one for all are still a
mystery such as in the situation where
Deku was able to break through the
control of heat-efficient sauce quark
during the tournament arc it appears
that the previous users of one-for-all
were somehow able to awaken inside Deku
and bring him back to its senses all
might has multiple attack techniques
which are named after states and cities
in the US like Detroit smash Texas mash
and Missouri smash according to almighty
to activate one for all the user must
clench their buttocks and scream smash
with in their hearts all my scores are
unbelievable six out of five in all
categories including power speed
technique intelligence and
cooperativeness and that is it guys all
the pro heroes in my hero academia
explained I really hope that you enjoyed
this video and that having all these
heroes in one place will be useful to
you if you did enjoy it be sure to 100%
Detroit smash that like button and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell because there are more my hero
academia videos on the way I want to
give a quick thank you to soul maka for
helping me out as well as my brother
goes on the other half of this channel
of course and Wow after working so long
in this video I feel like I've been at
it all night so if you made it this far
do me a favor and comment down below all
might all night as always thank you so
much for watching and until next time
the space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]